as we're taking our masks off now some
women do not want to
lose the masks there was a piece in uh
in a newspaper here headline
the people who want to keep masking it's
like
an invisibility cloak this is from the
guardian okay
and just interviewing generally just
women
who don't want to take their masks off
here are some of the quotes
tell me if this is about the science or
if this is about
something a little deeper quote i don't
want to feel the pressure of smiling at
people
to make sure everyone knows i'm friendly
and likable
both in quotes it's almost like taking
away the male
gaze this is some feminist term
i guess the feminists subject to men
having eyes so that's a feminist term
they don't like the male gaze
there's freedom in taking that power
back so this isn't about i'm afraid to
get the virus or whatever
this is i don't want to have to smile at
people
and this woman is framing it in a
feminist way saying this is about the
male gaze and taking power back from men
but no what this is about
is her selfishness and her
self-indulgence
she doesn't want to even have to smile
at people to show that she's friendly
and likable
that that most basic demand of society
to just sort of be friendly to smile and
not be ornery all the time
she doesn't want to have to take on that
obligation of society
she wants to do whatever she wants to do
at any given time and you can't say boo
about it another one quote
maybe it's because i'm a new yorker
maybe it's because i always feel like i
have to present my
best self to the world but it has been
such a relief to feel
anonymous it's like having a force field
around me
that says don't see me wow
this is really profound and especially
coming from a new yorker because
i think a lot of people believe that if
you're in a city you know a lot of
people because you're always around a
lot of people and if you're in a small
town you don't know that many people but
it's actually the opposite
if you're in a city you can be anonymous
if you're in a small town you cannot be
anonymous
and the people who are drawn toward that
sort of anonymity want more
and more and more of it the mask here
not about the science the mask being
about this idea that i can just totally
do whatever i want without being judged
for it
without being known think about this
when people have fantasies
they they'll often pretend to be
invisible
right they can they can just totally be
invisible when a little child is playing
one of the pretend games they'll play is
invisibility and i can just do whatever
i want and what
what invisibility fantasies and games
are about
is about the ability to live
without the the forces of the moral
universe on you
without the judgment without the
accountability i don't want to be
accountable to any i don't want anyone
to know who i am
and to hold me accountable for what i'm
doing and then finally quote it's a
common consensus among my co-workers
that we prefer not having customers see
our faces
not having customers see our faces often
times when a customer's being rude
or saying off-color political things
what does that mean being a republican
off-color political things meaning
non-leftist
i'm not allowed to grimace or make a
face because that will set them off
oh my goodness gracious this woman's
obviously in retail
the old expression the customer is
always right that's wrong according to
this woman
i am always right the the retail worker
is always right
when when a customer says or does
something that i don't like i'm not even
allowed to
grimace at them uh yeah you're not
because you're a retail worker you're in
a
you're doing your job oh my god yeah i'm
not allowed to
you know it's so outrageous when i'm
sitting here and doing this show i'm not
allowed to just uh
sit around and smoke a cigar and read a
book isn't that crazy i want to be able
to do that
i have to actually talk i have to
actually read things
out loud i have to react to things i
have to give my views
isn't that crazy that i can't just do
whatever i want even when i'm doing my
job
that's what this person is saying this
is what the liberal society does
on the left and the right for that
matter
the liberal society exalts entitlement
to selfishness and anonymity
this is why in a great many moral
matters
even in the cultural even the sexual
matters even in the social matters
the left and the right are almost in
perfect agreement
that all that matters is consent as long
as you consent to do something
people ought to be able to do whatever
they want now this is a very new idea
it used to be that at least actually the
left and the right in this country
both used to agree that society and the
moral order make some demands of us
and we have to do certain things and
true freedom true liberty is not just
doing whatever we want all the time
it's doing what we ought to do the right
to do what we ought to do that's true
liberty
then the left kind of lost that in the
60s maybe a little bit earlier
and then the left convinced the right to
adopt the same stupid view
which i detail at great length in my
opinion speechless controlling words
controlling minds
available now for pre-order you can also
get an autographed first
edition at premiere collectibles the
right adopted the left's view on this
sort of thing
and so now we basically just seek the
same things we seek a total private
sphere
no demands on us from society the way
this
expresses itself on the left is to say
that society is awful so it has no right
to make a demand
on us or to say that you know
our true selves are just whatever our
most base desires are and we have an
obligation to to follow those desires no
matter how crazy they are
that's how it expresses itself on the
left and on the right it expresses
itself in this kind of
ein rand craziness of you know the
virtue of selfishness
that actually charity and care for our
neighbors
somehow that's wrong because of some
paperback writer from the 20th century
who convinced people to throw away
the moral order and and the conservative
tradition
oh no do not go anywhere
before you subscribe before you ring
that bell very very important
finally the vouchers of the world are
letting us unmuzzle ourselves
big tech wants to keep us digitally
muzzled so make sure
you subscribe you will be able to get
all of the notifications
see on the next
you